if the only way that you can bear to be
around your friends is to drink you need
better friends and if the only sorts of
people that want you to be friends with
them are when you're destroying your
health along with them then you
definitely need better friends alcohol
is the only where if you don't do it
people assume you have a problem no one
says dude why are you why are you not
taking this evening I could be an option
not fancy smacking up tonight do we not
are we not are we not going to get like
blazed out of our mouth like no one says
that right it's alcohol alcohol has a
cultural position that is completely
different to every other and
most people I think have it in the back
of their mind that they probably would
be a bit of a better person if they took
a break from drinking and people can get
pretty upset when you start to throw
into harsh contrast
the errors and lapses that they know
that they're making on a daily basis